so it used to be if you had a late night
tv show your job was to entertain people
it's late people are tired they want to
be amused they want to laugh
you give them comedy
but the rules have changed now if you
have a late night tv show your job is to
provide wooden corporate propaganda at
full force beat people over the head
with talking points until they submit
that's what they're doing
last night seven late night hosts
gathered for a special climate
on climate you can imagine how fun that
was
and how honest
here's some of it
if you are a person living on this
planet your future is in peril that's a
scientific fact and yes there are other
issues that are all very important the
pandemic
systemic racism income inequality
immigration gun violence but here's the
thing if we don't address climate change
none of those issues will matter at all
the car is going off a cliff and we're
fiddling with the radio we are way past
climate denial oh yeah oh we gotta act
soon and you have to give us more power
or else you'll die
because it turns out the root cause of
climate change is not actually carbon
it's you
you did it
stephen colbert explained that people
who believe in god are responsible for
climate change
are you saying are you saying that
individual actions are useless because
these corporations are the real problem
no
oh good because i'm not it's also
religion sorry because the concept of an
afterlife gives you people the false
hope of an escape hatch
oh religious people
right
they're the ones who murdered
tens of millions of people in the 20th
century wasn't the atheists
colbert was honest enough to acknowledge
he doesn't follow any of these climate
rules because they're for you not him
and i mean this sincerely i'm a huge
hypocrite i'll never do anything that's
inconvenient to me that's why there has
to be systemic change backed up by
government action to make everyone make
the right choices
not the easy ones
wait a second if someone forces you to
do something
it's not really a choice is it you can't
make someone make the right choices that
doesn't even make sense if you make
someone do something it's a command
that person is your slave you own that
person no choice involved
not to be pedantic hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else